vanessa parker et son mari james rhyner
ont toujours voulu changer les choses
cette fois ci ils se lancent tous les
deux en politique elle comme sénatrice à
la législature de l'état de la georgie
lui à la chambre des représentants et le
changement passe aussi par le combat
contre les tactiques de suppression de
vote de certains électeurs les
organismes comme news georgia project
continue de surveiller et de dénoncer ce
genre de manoeuvres politiques anti
démocratique
mais on voit que
le gouvernement choisit de mettre en
place des lois avec des implications
partie sans ces tactiques pour
décourager les électeurs ont toujours
existé vient des formes selon enjoy
gillespie les obstacles empêchant de
voter augmente depuis une décision de la
cour suprême en 2013 qui n'oblige plus
décomptés discriminant les minorités
entre autres à avoir l'approbation des
autorités fédérales pour modifier leurs
lois électorales entre 2016 et 2018 à
travers le pays ce sont plus de 17
millions d'électeurs qui ont disparu des
listes électorales pour de multiples
raisons
et même si ce sont plus souvent
qu'autrement les républicains qui
utilisent ces stratégies
les politiciens en général en sont
responsables selon notre couple
d'aspirants élus les jours des
magouilles politiques si légal soit
elles sont comptés grâce à la démocratie
les longues files d'attentes pour le
vote par anticipation depuis quelques
jours démontrent selon eux une volonté
de changement